The 2017 film version of Stephen King's It
made its mark as one of the biggest critical
and commercial hits of the year, but it wasn't
the first time the horror master's classic
1986 story made its way to the screen.
The book's original adaptation, a 1990 TV
miniseries, lacked a movie-sized budget and
modern special effects, but it still managed
to give audiences plenty of scares.
The TV version of It had a strong cast going
for it, including budding young stars and
formidable character actors portraying the
adults.
With the exception of Jonathan Brandis and
John Ritter, who've passed away since the
movie's release, most of It's original cast
is still busy with strong Hollywood careers.
Here's a look back at the original ensemble
and what they've been up to in the 27 years
since Pennywise last reared his head.
Richard Thomas
TV fans might best remember Richard Thomas
for his Emmy-winning turn as "John-Boy" in
the The Waltons.
But for horror fans, Richard Thomas will always
be remembered as the grownup version of Bill
Denbrough, taking over the role of the Losers'
leader from Jonathan Brandis.
After It, Thomas continued his prolific acting
career with more films like Wonder Boys and
TV series such as The Americans.
Thomas also maintains a steady career on the
stage, recently earning a Tony Award nomination
for his role in the 2017 Broadway revival
of The Little Foxes.
Brandon Crane
In the 1990 miniseries, Brandon Crane played
the young version of Ben Hanscom, who was
frequently bullied by Henry Bowers and his
gang because of his weight.
Around the same time, Crane also had a recurring
role on the classic drama-comedy series The
Wonder Years as Kevin's close friend Doug
Porter.
Following his appearance in It, Crane continued
to appear on the small screen and in short
films, and these days he makes his living
as a stage actor, singer, and front-end website
developer.
During the summer of 2017, Crane reunited
with some of the other Derry alums to film
the upcoming documentary, Pennywise: The Story
of 'IT.'
Emily Perkins
Canadian actress Emily Perkins portrayed the
young version of Beverly Marsh in the miniseries,
and it was one of her first major roles.
But something about her stint as a scream
queen in It seemed to stick, because she would
later continue to star in scary projects like
The X-Files and and Ginger Snaps.
Nowadays, she's taking a break from the small
screen as she enjoys her newest role as mom.
Annette O'Toole
Before she became the adult Beverly Marsh
in It, Annette O'Toole appeared as Clark Kent's
love interest Lana Lang in Superman III.
And after defeating the Derry demon, O'Toole
returned to the Smallville fold by starring
as the Superman's mother on the small screen.
After that was done, however, she came back
to the realm of Stephen King for a brief stint
on the small screen adaptation of 11.22.63.
Seth Green
Long before he became a household name, Seth
Green was the foul-mouthed wisecracking Richie
Tozier in the It miniseries.
He later rose to fame with roles in the Austin
Powers film franchise, his long-running role
as Oz on Buffy the Vampire Slayer, and the
dozens of other films and TV shows he's been
a part of.
Nowadays, his steadiest work seems to happen
behind a microphone: he provides voices for
Family Guy, Robot Chicken and Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles, and even made into the Marvel
Universe as the voice of Howard the Duck in
the Guardians of the Galaxy movies.
Harry Anderson
For adult Richie, actor-comedian Harry Anderson
stepped into the role.
"Beep beep Richie" "I didn't hear that."
Anderson is likely better known for his long-running
role as Judge Harry Stone in the NBC sitcom
Night Court, but he's also popped up in popular
series like Cheers and Hearts Afire.
But much like Richie, he's always had comedy
at heart, and these days, he can be seen performing
stand-up routines and magic shows around the
country.
Adam Faraizl
Twelve-year-old Eddie Kaspbrak
was the most timid member of the Losers' Club,
frequently jumping at his own shadow or complaining
of ailments, like asthma, that his mother
convinced him he suffered from.
Playing Eddie in the 1990 miniseries was Adam
Faraizl, who didn't stick with acting for
long after It premiered on television.
He made a handful of appearances in TV movies
like Where the Red Fern Grows, but ultimately
he found a professional passion in the restaurant
business where he specializes in bar beverages.
Dennis Christopher
Playing the adult version of Eddie Kaspbrak
in the It miniseries was Dennis Christopher,
who first rose to prominence in Hollywood
with his starring role as Dave in the 1979
film Breaking Away.
Christopher went on to appear in many more
films and television shows over the years,
including Roswell and Star Trek: Enterprise.
He also appeared in Quentin Tarantino's Django
Unchained and recently starred in several
episodes of the Epix comedy series Graves.
Marlon Taylor
Playing young Mike Hanlon was actor Marlon
Taylor, who also appeared in a handful of
other television roles as a child, including
Sister, Sister.
After 1994, Taylor took a hiatus from acting,
but reappeared in 2009 when he co-starred
in the rap drama Know Thy Enemy.
Information about what he's been up to since
then is scarce, but according to Taylor's
Twitter account, he recently finished filming
a part for an episode in season four of Syfy's
post-apocalyptic TV series Z-Nation.
Tim Reid
Tim Reid played out the rest of Mike Hanlon's
tale for viewers, as he discovers that It
has returned 27 years after their last encounter.
Like his younger counterpart Marlon Taylor,
Tim Reid also appeared on the sitcom Sister,
Sister and continued to act in a number of
films and television shows, including That
'70s Show and Treme.
Most recently, Reid made a couple of appearances
as Bishop Lionel Jeffries in the Oprah Winfrey
Network drama series Greenleaf.
Ben Heller
Being an actor isn't for everyone, and it
certainly seems that was the case for Ben
Heller, who played the 12-year-old version
of Stanley Uris in 1990.
Stan is the most logical — and skeptical
— of the Losers' Club members, and Heller
handled the role just fine.
However, his appearance as Stan was his first
and last acting role.
Fans will get to finally find out what he's
been up to in his post-Derry days when he
appears on the 2018 documentary about the
mini-series' production.
Richard Masur
Stan was the one who initiated the blood oath
between the Losers' Club members when they
were children.
But when he learns that he'll have to make
good on that promise, his fear of facing the
ancient evil again leads him to take his own
life.
"Sorry I'm late."
Richard Masur is probably better known for
his work in shows like Rhoda and films like
The Thing.
Today, he's still a regular on the small screen,
having recently starred in The Good Wife and
Orange is the New Black.
Tim Curry
Renowned actor Tim Curry did much of the heavy
lifting in the 1990 It miniseries with his
role as Pennywise the Dancing Clown.
While there has been considerable buzz surrounding
Bill Skarsgård's modern take on the character
in the 2017 film adaptation, it still doesn't
displace Curry's cheeky performance as a fan
favorite from the first adaptation.
Following It, Curry continued his extremely
prolific acting career with dozens of roles
in films and television shows.
And even after suffering a stroke in 2012
which left him wheelchair-bound, Curry refused
to slow down, taking a voice role in Star
Wars: The Clone Wars and returning to The
Rocky Horror Picture Show realm as the Criminologist
in the Fox TV remake.
And he's still ready to bust out Pennywise
whenever the need arises:
"And we say down here we float."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!